ينضم الينا من مدينه
بوجمبوره في بوروندي بين ضوء وزير خارجيه
جنوب السودان السيده الوزير مرحبا بك كان
هناك اتصال
اجراه رئيس جنوب السودان مع كل من البرهان
واحميتي عما اسفر وهل هناك مبادره واضحه
من دوله جنوب السودان
شكرا جزيلا اولا وانا هنا في مدينه
بوجمبوره
للتوسط في قضيه مع الكونغو
السعاده الرئيسه فخامه الرئيس سيلفا في
بدء محاولاتهم في الثاني من مايو واترى
اتصالاته مع الجنرال البرهان
والجنرال وهذا ما اريد ان اتحدث اليكم
حوله اليوم
ما هو فحوى هذا الاتصال
وماذا اسفر
هذه المحادثات
كان هناك اتفاق مبدئي من جانبي كلا
الطرفين الجنرال البرهان اتفقا على ان
هدنه تبدا اليوم
وتستمر حتى الحادي عشر من الجدران حمدتي
ايضا قبل من حيث المبدا هذا العرض وارسل
رسالتين منفصلتين
وايضا
ان يكون هناك هدنه من سبعه ايام اليوم هو
البدايه اليوم اليوم الاول لهذه الهده من
سبعه ايام
وايضا في الخرطوم اليوم
وفي اماكن اخرى
تم خرق هذه الهدنه وهذا اثار قلقا بالغا
لدى فخامه الرئيس البكاء يعني الهدنه التي
اقترح ها الرئيس الباكر ووافق عليها طرفان
لم تحترم
في الحقيقه بدات هدنه اليوم
وكان لدينا قلق
وفخامه الرئيس
بسبب قلقه اتصل
برئيس الجمهوريه جزر القمر وايضا قاده ابن
الاتحاد الافريقي لبحث حاله الهدنه
الحاليه في السودان
طيب وماذا وما هي النتيجه يعني هدنه من
سبعه ايام لم تحترم
وايضا هناك اتصالات يقوم بها الرئيس
الباكر ايضا حتى الان لم تنعكس على الارض
في شيء ماذا ايضا
سيقوم الرئيس
الجنوب السوداني
[موسيقى]
لهذا السبب فخامه الرئيس اليوم اتصل
بالرئيس البرهان مساء هذا اليوم
ليعرض عن قلقه
عن عن عدم احترامي الهدنه اليوم وايضا
فخامه الرئيس ايضا حاول الاتصال هاتفيا
بحمدتي لكن الاتصال لم يتم لعدم التمكن من
اتمام الاتصال هاتفيا لكنه اتصل بالرئيس
البرهان واعرض عن قلقي عن خلق الهدنه
لا ادري ان كنت قد تبعت ما قاله وكيل
وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه بان بلاده ليست
بحاجه لمبادرات وساطه هل جنوب السودان
معني بهذا الكلام
في الحقيقه نحن نتدخل بناء على دعوه من
الايجاد ومن السودانيين انفسهم من الرئيس
البرهان
وايضا من قائد القوات الدعم السريع حمدتي
وهناك اتفاق على ان الحال يجب ان يكون بين
السودانيين انفسهم
هل لديكم الان يعني
تقول انه جرى اتصال هذا المساء مع
البرهان لكن لم يتم التمكن
باتذكر مع حماتي هل لديكم مبادره جديده هل
سيطرح شيئا جديدا الرئيس سيلفاكار بتكليف
من الايجاد
انها ليست مبادره جديده
لهذا السبب الرئيس سيلفا كان اتصل
باستمرار رئيس الاتحاد الافريقي
والفخامه الرئيس سلفا بحث معه بشكل مطول
وضعيه وقف اطلاق النار
واهميه تمثيل الحكومه السودانيه
والقاده الدعم السريع لكي يكون هناك
محاولات لوضع حظ لهذه الحرب المستمره منذ
ثلاثه اسابيع وكان هناك تاكيد على اهميه
الاتحاد الافريقي
والايجاد وطبعا الافارقه يعتبرون ان
المشكلات يجب ان تتم على ايدي الافارقه
انفسهم لهذا السبب الرئيس سيلفا بحث
الرئيسي الاتحاد الافريقي هذه القضيه طيب
هل ابلغتم بان الطرفين سيرسلان
مبعوثين الى او ممثلين الى جنوب السودان
من اجل المحادثات هذا الامر كان مطروح
سابقا هل ابلغتهم به رسميا
اليوم الرئيس البرهان
واخبر السفير سلفا بان مبعوثا خاصا
سياتي يوم الاحد
وسوف ينقل الرساله
ونحن نامل بانه بعد الانتهاء من تلك
الزياره سيكون هناك
مبعوث خاطئه الى جوبا يوم الاحد ايضا
فقط يعني
البرهان سيرسل مبعوثا يحمل رساله لكن ليس
هناك في المقابل مبعوث من حماتي من اجل
الالتقاء في جنوب السودان للتفاوض
[موسيقى]
نحن نعمل ان يوم الاحد ما زال بعد ثلاثه
ايام من الان وان
تبادل الرسائل من الرئيس سيلفا الى برهان
وحميدتي
ستؤدي الى استجابه من من جانبيهما ويستغل
فرصه هذه الايام الثلاثه ليبعثان بمبعوثين
الينا من مدينه بوجمبوره في بوروندي بين
الضوء وزير خارجيه جنوب السودان شكرا
جزيلا لك